in 1957 a cultist Alice a Bailey wrote
that in this year 2025 we would see
demons openly publicly no longer hidden
is this prophecy being fulfilled right
in front of our eyes let's take a look
you know people get scared of Alice a
Bailey cuz it's like it's the occult you
know she was this top un Acolyte and
founder of Lucifer's trust publishing
house so she's an open avowed luciferian
wrote the book The externalization of
the hierarchy capital Capital H when she
writes that in her book and she calls
them the Masters again capital M demon
spirits and the externalization of that
Global power structure hierarchy she
says will begin in
2025 and wrote this nearly a hundred
years ago so what does that mean
externalization of the hierarchy well we
think of the hierarchy of the world as
like K Claus Schwab and Bill Gates and
human beings and they are just human
beings the prince of this world Satan is
called the prince of this world he he by
fraud he took Dominion of this planet he
goes up to the council with the sons of
God and God says to Satan where have you
come from this is in Job chapter 1 he
says walking back and forth on the earth
in other words like a lion pacing that's
my territory exactly and he said to
Jesus all these kingdoms have been given
to me and I can give them to whomsoever
I please if you will Bow Down and
Worship me so he's the prince of this
world there's a hierarchy of entities
not without God's sovereignty ruling
over this is the weeds and the wheat the
farmer says you got to let those weeds
grow under the Harvest and otherwise
you'll pull up the wheat with them when
they're small so in other words Satan's
principles are being developed so that
all Minds will say never going that
route again Rebellion against God that's
destructive but for the time being we
have a prince of this world running
around and that she says Alice a Bailey
says that this hierarchy these Masters
will openly unveil themselves and walk
walk on the physical plane visibly on
this Earth and and she's dating these
this period of the externalization of
the hierarchy where they reveal
themselves to and it doesn't have to be
in 2025 it begins then and I don't have
any assumptions about how many years we
have before the Lord returns so I want
to be ready now but know I don't want to
be too dogmatic about it's got to be
2025 but that's what's coming I think
that's why God cautions us to to not
order our faith after our eyes I mean
even fire comes down from heaven like
that's not that's not representative of
that came from God he's like look I've
given you all the information for you to
study and you should know this through
and through that your faith be built on
this thing here not what you see it's
built on the message not the miracle
that's right absolutely because people
aren't going to be able to believe their
they're going to believe their eyes and
they won't they will disbelieve the word
of God oh yeah you start seeing demons
out in your real world experience I mean
you better bet that's going to shake
some people's faith and do you think
they will look demonic or Satan
transforms himself into an angel of
Light masquerades as an angel of Light
and here's an interesting thought you
know Roger monno the late Roger Moro boy
if we could have him at this table we
got his old videos he he's done these
interviews and he's written his books he
was an initiate into a satanic secret
society if there you've got listeners
who are not aware of Roger morau and so
he spoke at length with the satanic high
priest high level about what the plans
of the enemy are and one of those things
he said says the grandm plan at the end
will be that the demon spirits will
appear just like Alice Bailey says
appear but they will declare themselves
to be inhabitants of far Distant Worlds
oh yeah what's up with the alien
Obsession lately you've got hearings in
Congress you've got politicians you've
got the Vatican they're all aliens
aliens why where did this come from is
is that going to be the externalization
where they walk openly but masquerading
as we and says they will according to
the satanic high priest that he got this
from and then he became a Christian
Broke Free from it and did the tell all
and he says um they will come saying
we're here to tell you what to do so
that you don't bring destruction upon
yourselves it's peace and safety peace
and safety and I think Hollywood has
done a disservice to the whole world
because they've put out this idea out
that an alien is
this so if it doesn't come as this like
nasty looking thing and all of a sudden
it's an angel of Light Well it can't be
an alien like what we've seen in
Hollywood that must be from God it's
like they've already primed everybody's
mind to just accept them if they're
beautiful yep Satan is serving up allart
spiritualism you know he's got something
for every different kind of people group
for some people it's aliens for other
people it's different things you know
but he's ready to deceive the masses
with all kinds of different forms if you
like this video like comment subscribe
and hit the notification Bell so you
know when we launch new videos and drop
a comments below and we'll try to get
back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say